so the other big topic that i'm sure
will come up tonight is obviously this
new york times report on
president trump's taxes so first things
first if somebody actually leaked
proprietary information on trump's
taxes from like the irs to the uh
to the new york times that's illegal uh
that should be somewhat disturbing to
all of us now i've been a proponent for
a long time that trump should have
released his tax returns in 2016
and then certainly after he was
president he should have just released
his tax returns like what the hell was
the downside of just releasing
the tax returns i'm also not of the
opinion that this is going to be an
entirely damage-free scenario for trump
because what they report is that trump
in the last couple of years has paid
like a combined 1500 bucks
in federal taxes and the natural
reaction of people is not a logical one
namely that our system itself is screwed
up that our deduction system is
really messed up in this country that we
should basically just have a flat tax in
this country and we should get rid of
all of the deductions
entirely instead of that people react
with well he's a rich guy why isn't he
paying lots of taxes okay the answer is
that over the years he's
i'm sure paid many many many taxes also
it is true that he has not done anything
illegal
so normally in a situation like this
you'd have to ask yourself okay so what
did trump do wrong
so there are a few accusations as to
what trump could have done wrong here
one he did something illegal on his
taxes like tax fraud
presumably the irs would be all over
that too he could have obtained
some sort of nefarious financial aid
from some nefarious foreign players
there's no evidence
of that or three you somehow think that
just because you're rich
you should be giving more money to the
government than you're actually legally
obligated to do which is idiotic and
even joe biden doesn't do that as it
turns out
joe biden has been spending years
dodging the payroll tax
i mean in august the wall street journal
reported
that the the bidens dodged the payroll
tax they used an s corp to avoid paying
more than half a million dollars in
levies for medicare and obamacare
as well apparently both he and jill went
out of their way to avoid funding
seniors entitlement benefits according
to their tax returns in 2017 and 2018
the bidens and his wife jill avoided
payroll taxes on nearly 13.3 million
dollars in income from book royalties
and speaking fees they did so by
classifying the income as s corp
profits rather than taxable wages the
bidens did pay themselves salaries from
their corporations of nearly 750
thousand dollars between them
over two years they paid full taxes on
that income but they circumvented the
payroll tax
on the nearly 95 percent of that income
that remained
a tax expert interviewed by the journal
in 2019 called the biden schema pretty
aggressive
another told the paper it served solely
to avoid the payroll taxes
of the taxes the biden's avoided 2.9
percent of their income
about 385 thousand dollars would have
funded medicare the other 0.9
nearly 120 thousand dollars was part of
obamacare and fund that law so here's
the rule
did they do anything illegal no did
trump do anything illegal no
if you don't like the tax code good idea
you can restructure it also if you're
complaining about the fact that
president trump didn't pay enough tax
you should also point out that trump
lowered taxes for everyone
specifically more so on the bottom end
of the scale
okay in sheer absolute numbers whenever
there's a tax cut people at the top
make the most money because people at
the top had the most money to make
but in terms of the disproportionate
benefit of the taxes
it really hit people lower down on the
on the income scale more than it hit
people higher up on the income scale
if you're not just talking like sure
absolute numbers if you're talking about
percentage decreases or if you are
talking
about the benefits that are received
under the tax bill people like me living
in california i actually got shellacked
by the trump tax cuts because it got rid
of the state and local tax deductions
so that meant that i had to pay both my
state and federal taxes one on top of
the other as opposed to taking the state
taxes in california
and taking them against the federal
taxes in any case what exactly is the
bombshell here so the new york times
reports that donald trump paid 750
50 total 750 in federal income taxes the
year he won the presidency
in his first year in the white house he
paid another 750 period not 750
750 bucks like the cost of
you know a couple of car payments he
paid no income taxes at all
in 10 of the previous 15 years largely
because he reported losing much more
money
than he made according to the new york
times as the president wages a
re-election campaign that polls say he's
in danger of losing his finances are
under stress beset by losses and
hundreds of millions of dollars in debt
coming due that he has personally
guaranteed
also hanging over him is a decade-long
audit battle with the irs over the
legitimacy of a 72.9 million
tax refund he claimed and received after
declaring huge losses an adverse ruling
could cost him more than 100 million
dollars
the tax returns that trump has long
fought to keep private tell a
story fundamentally different from the
one he has sold to the american public
his reports to the irs portray a
businessman who takes in hundreds of
millions of dollars a year
yet racks up chronic losses that he
aggressively employs to avoid paying
taxes
now with financial challenges mounting
the records show he depends more and
more
on making money from businesses that put
him in potential and often direct
conflict of interest with his job
as president so somehow the new york
times obtained tax return data extending
more than two decades for trump
and the hundreds of companies that make
up his business again this is probably a
legal violation
in some way trump for his part called
them fake news
he said i have paid taxes he said i've
litigated this before you can't
simultaneously say that they are fake
news and also that you have
and and also that you're smart for
avoiding taxes which is something that
he has said
in the past the new york times dean
paquette put out a full note talking
about why they put this out and the
answer is because they hate donald trump
and they say we're not making the
records themselves public because we do
not want to jeopardize our sources who
have taken enormous personal risks to
help inform the public
we are publishing this report because we
believe citizens should understand as
much as possible about their leaders and
representatives their priorities their
experiences
and also their finances so in other
words we are it's not a violation of law
for the new york times to do this
just a note the new york times was a lot
more
divided in nature about publishing the
wikileaks stuff which again
i think there's a case we made we
shouldn't publish the wikileaks stuff
would than they have been about
publishing trump's taxes
the the basic idea here is threefold
from democrats one
trump is not the successful businessman
he says he is which
i mean okay sure
also whatever you think about how trump
has handled his businesses he has not
used
public office in order to enrich himself
joe biden was worth no money then he was
vice president
now he's worth tens of millions of
dollars barack obama had the same deal
like his net worth when he
when he entered office was like a
million bucks or something and now
barack obama is probably worth
nine figures he's probably 100 million
dollars now it turns out that people who
make money after being in public office
post significantly more of a threat to
the institutional architecture of the
republic than people who had a lot of
money going in
i've always been bewildered by the idea
that if you were rich before you went in
somehow this is a demerit
it seems like that should actually be a
merit but it is true that part of
trump's pitch for a long time has been
that he is world breaking business
genius
and i've doubted that story for a very
long time i've always said i'm not even
sure that he's worth a billion dollars
that doesn't mean that he's poor but it
doesn't mean that he is not the great
businessman
he said he was okay that's a hit but
it's not much of one
the other hit is supposedly that trump
is
dodging taxes okay and again there's no
evidence of this the new york times
itself
says there is no evidence either that
trump has dodged taxes or has violated
the law
or that he is in hawks of the rooskies
and yet those are all narratives that
democrats are trying to throw out there
today
so first of all as far as paying no
taxes that actually is not breaking news
all the way back in 2016 hillary clinton
suggested that trump paid no taxes
and trump said in open debate right i
didn't pay taxes because i'm smart not
stupid
maybe he doesn't want the american
people all of you watching tonight
to know that he's paid nothing in
federal taxes because the only years
that anybody has ever seen were a couple
of years when he had to turn them over
to state authorities when he was trying
to get a casino license and they showed
he didn't pay any federal income tax so
that makes me smarter i paid
zero okay so he said that makes me far
smarter
right he he comes back he's making me
far smarter than anybody else
okay again it's not like there's a big
secret everybody has sort of speculated
about this for a very long
time and the new york times shows no
evidence of illegality that doesn't stop
carl bernstein worse than watergate carl
bernstein
carl bernstein has spent his entire
career just saying worse than watergate
ever since watergate so this is worse
than watergate too ukraine was worse
than watergate
from talking about the election was
worse than watergate everything is worse
than watergate for carl bernstein
this is really the smoking gun of a
pervasively
criminal presidency we have a president
of the united states who is a grifter
his family are grifters and this is the
definitive evidence of it
this once again points to the
president's foreign entanglements
for his own political purposes and his
own financial good there are certainly
implications of tax
fraud to be to begin with that needs to
be looked at and and will be looked at
remember that one time he reported a
story and it was like 15 years before i
was born and we're going to pretend like
he's still a relevant figure carl
bernstein
okay so that story is done the idea that
he did anything illegal if he did
we have an entire wing of the federal
government that is designed to go after
people
who violate tax law okay the second
attack
is that he is in hock to the ruski's
there's no evidence he's in hot to the
rooskies in fact it says directly in
many of the documents i think it's page
35 of his disclosures
federal disclosures who he owes money to
that doesn't stop kamala harris from
doing the
who do you owe money to president trump
heroes kamala harris who does he owe the
money to
tell us who do you owe the money to and
um
do you owe debt to any foreign nation
do you who you know do you owe debt do
you owe money let's just be clear about
what debt means you owe somebody money
do you owe anybody money who is impacted
by any decision you make as president of
the united states
we need to know that okay again there's
no evidence
that he is being in any way twisted
around by foreign adversaries remember
they tried they've been trying this crap
since 2016. and they're not going to
stop
right nancy pelosi then suggested that
that trump's debt is a national security
question what does putin have on him
they never changed the tune i mean guys
stick and move a little bit
nancy pelosi the adult nancy pelosi
continuing to suggest that this is all
about what putin does all roads lead to
putin is nancy pelosi's routine
it's just it's absurd this is absurd you
guys are making mockeries of yourself
this president appears to have over 400
million dollars in debt 420 whatever it
is
million dollars in debt to whom
different countries what is the leverage
they have so for me
this is a national security question
the question is what does putin have on
the president politically
personally financially in every way that
the president would try to undermine
our commitment to nato okay this is just
i'm sorry this is so tiring this kind of
crap is so tight
and then msnbc has on the greatest of
all political analysts a person who once
played a politician on tv
you know we're now beyond the point of
parity
i mean do you remember there was a
commercial back in the 1970s in which a
guy who played a doctor on general
hospital led off the commercial by
saying
i'm not a doctor but i play one on tv
okay well now you got jeff daniels
who was not in fact a newsman but played
one on tv
now he's talking about his theories
about trump's taxes because we need to
hear from jeff
daniels okay here's jeff daniels on that
great news network msnbc
what are they talking about in helsinki
what were you know all the stuff i mean
there's all of that the tax returns that
he won't show us it's so obvious
and where is he getting the money where
did he get all the money
and and i mean all roads as
speaker pelosi said all roads lead to
putin and
you know time's running out this is a
bad movie we're living through that's
what this is
life and death he should know bad movies
i mean honest to god he really should
but that that is
that is very solid stuff right there
from jeff daniels definitely needed to
hear from
from that guy from the dumb and dumber
guy i need to hear from him right now
get him on the line stat we need to hear
from jeff daniels right now stat
on trump's taxes okay the final angle of
course is that trump is poorer than he
said he is and that's really bad
again do i think it looks good for trump
to pay 750 bucks in taxes over the last
couple years
no i i don't but would it matter they
went after mitt romney and said that
mitt romney didn't pay his taxes he paid
effective tax rate harry reid just lied
about it is any of this going to make a
serious done for trump
probably not is it going to come up
tonight probably but again
do i think it's that the media are going
to gog over this thing and i'm just like
why you don't have enough material
against trump you got to go to this
seriously facts don't care about your
feelings and it's a fact that the ben
shapiro show is the largest conservative
podcast in the nation
be sure to hit the subscribe button to
stay up to date on all of our content